hello and welcome to gamespot of thrones
gamespot's weekly show about Westeros
esos and everything in between I am Lucy
James joined this week by Kate gray
hello and Dave jewett hi there right
we're very excited because season six
has finally started we've seen episode 1
the red woman and we're going to be
discussing it in depth there will be
spoilers of plenty so if you haven't
seen the episode what are you doing here
go watch it come back guys let's do this
let's start then with the briefest of
rundowns about where all the characters
are what they're up to Dave why don't
you kick off with the north well we're
starting season six as we ended season
five Castle black with a shot of seems
to be dead John snow in the aftermath of
his assassination the thousand stabs for
the watch really sir Davos finds his
body ghost is crying in his kennel and
as a divorce is standing over Jon Snow
the four people that you could really
count as loyal to John find him take him
into a room barricade themselves in with
ghosts because they know the watches
against them at this point they're not
safe where they are but upon bringing
Melisandre into the room she seems very
quite weary about John she's this is
like the second person he's she's put
her faith in and he's gone you could see
like the Life just drain out of her but
Davis has a great idea of sending one of
the Nights Watch to find the wildlings
the people who John has saved and
probably the only people that can
actually be called upon Wildings that
they are and well then we just have to
wait and see what's happening to the
Nights Watch after you know sir alistair
Thorne has admitted treason and murder
but the night's was just like yeah well
you know well let it slide yes weird
right yeah especially since he was like
I did this for honor I did this for duty
and like part of that is you know
treason Stabbin doesn't seem very
honorable of you sir do many of them
care and I think any of them cared that
there was a slight outbursts being like
traitor okay I'm sorry yeah we know all
murderers and rapists anyway the
murderers and rapists was on a no
apparently and then we move you know a
little bit south and go to Winterfell
you see Ramsay over the the body of the
kennel masters daughter we see the first
hint of his emotion and he ruined it all
by telling telling the maester to feed
her to the hounds okay Ramsay well back
to back to you of old self I see it's
recycling yeah she is the kennel moving
back to you and Bruce basically tells
him you've lost answer she's the key to
the north we need her for Winterfell we
need her for an heir and for legitimacy
get back and that's when we see Rams
santi and reek Santi Santi Sansa and
wreak fleeing through the woods of
Winterfell chased by Ramsay's dogs have
been cornered reek did like kind of
selflessly offer himself to the nights
of chasing them which is like seems like
his part of his Redemption I want to
call him Theon again so soon and it all
looks like it's going sour but good ol
Brienne of Tarth turns up just that
they're just at the last second saves
the day we see her take down four of the
men arms of the flayed flayed man
Podrick obviously taking note of his
training kills one and then reek / Theon
kills the other mmm and that was a
pretty intense northing that was going
on yeah I'll take the south then so sir
see basically discovers that Jamie after
after returning from Dawn has failed
masalas dead and Cersei kind of opens up
to Jamie about her prophecy from Maggy
the Frog and that she knows that she
would have three children and she knew
that they would all die so its way that
she's kind of stealing herself at amon
he's you know obviously her only
remaining child whereas she's stealing
us off preparing to lose him and you
know wishing that masala was still alive
was Jamie's like [ __ ] prophecy [ __ ]
Facebook everyone who isn't us so that's
kind of like the new Lannister motto I
guess is a Jaime and Cersei if everyone
isn't us up everything that is knows
then we go to snore I mean dawn stuff
actually does happen in Dorne but I died
i dodo I just tune out so Prince Doran
gets stabbed to death by ilaria sand and
the women sort of
rise up and take dawn I guess they say
that no weak man will have a rule here
and dawn again so the kill Prince Doran
and they also kill his son Prince
trystane I mean okay poor guy I mean
after he's painting those lovely eyes
for his beloved r.i.p myself yeah yeah i
know i don't know i think the dawn
plotlines just stretch on little too
long now kate across the Narrow Sea so
first of all we see Tyrion and Varys
walking through marine now marine used
to be bustling metropolis and now it's
kind of abandoned tools have been just
left on the floor everything's broken
and it turns out that actually it's fear
that's keeping these citizens inside
whether they're scared of the sons of
the harpy or the dragons or of
everything just turning completely sour
as soon as Daenerys walked in who knows
why not all of them so that's happening
but meanwhile tenaris has been captured
by a khalasar which is you know familiar
territory for her so you think she'd be
okay she's listening to them say some
rather unsavory things about her and
then she reveals that were all along
mishary Quran has Drago [ __ ]
I've droegled Reba and Anna's circle I'm
have your vaca model that saves her from
rape and death and probably all sorts of
nasty things but it does mean that
technically she should be in phase
Dothrak with a load of other widows
excellent curly sees zyzz so that's
where she is meanwhile aria is in
Braavos she's blind she's sitting on the
steps begging along with those of other
beggars not really doing too well she's
not great beggar but then the wave turns
up and starts being her with a stick and
you know at first were thinking vasp it
fair she's blind but then she is I'll
see you tomorrow and then maybe maybe
it's training maybe she'll get better
maybe the waif isn't just well she's a
colossal [ __ ] this massive [ __ ] I
can't see that's your problem not mine
that's where we are with this episode
Dave initial thoughts did you enjoy it I
really enjoyed it i think it's it's
setting up for a lot of things i see a
lot of people are kind of disappointed
that there was some plot holes which i
don't think there was that many of you
just talking about the dogs going miss
well the dogs did go missing where did
they go mommy said they're his best
hands they just bolted but hey better
than go back to ramsey and eating his
dead girlfriend whoever but i really
enjoy this episode sets up a lot it's
true backed back to its true Game of
Thrones South some cool deaths some
wonderful people great acting and what
else do we need episode one could only
get better from here yeah 10 yes n
strong words Katie agree see I think
it's more of a seven yeah and this is
why I think it was a great episode but
when I actually look back on it the the
exciting deaths were very quickly
glossed over they happened in a very
quick space of time one minute trust
ain't like I've got some eyes the next
minute he doesn't even have a face so
that was probably the best moment of the
episode that and brianne other than that
there was a lot of sort of walking and
talking and
no I don't like that quite as much no
it's fair enough I don't know I really
liked it i mean when Brian came and I
think in my notes I genuinely is wrote
yes so I just said that out loud as we
watching the episode yeah that too but
now I really enjoyed this episode it's
as Dave said it sets up a lot which
we're gonna get into now open let's do a
little bit of analysis ever someone of
season six left me feeling strangely
optimistic for the outcome of some of
the characters in in Westeros especially
alien Alex answer some nice allegiances
were made people got out of some tricky
situations Kate we write to put our
trust in george RR martin that these
characters are gonna you know live happy
long lives i would love to say yes Lucy
but every time something good has
happened even when it's something bad
happening to a bad character it always
gets flipped you know like Joffrey dies
and you're like yes finally but then all
the good people get blamed they get
thrown in prison you have to escape it
all sounds horrible again it turns sour
in your mouth and I've actually been
analyzing how george RR martin writes
these seasons with obviously the writers
of the next few seasons because those
books don't exist yet come on sesh at
the start of each season right
everything always seems quite peachy so
in season 4 you've got overran swatting
around being like I'm great I'm going to
revenge everybody and then he dies
you've got dinero's getting some dragons
and then the Dragons you know go through
their awkward teenage years and that's
what happening right now you've got
robbed and winning the war and then you
know the red wedding so every time a
season starts it goes hey maybe he'll
turn out okay and they never do so bear
that in mind so in this episode we've
got Sansa and Theon being friends
finally reach attention Brienne turning
up and saving them just to the last
minute that was good that wouldn't
normally happen normally they die and
that would be the end of them and you've
got divorce going maybe we can be saved
by the world links you've got area being
maybe being trained to be a badass in
Braavos where no one's trying to kill
her yet
no they're all going to die or at the
very least something awful will happen
to them what I find quite interesting is
that weirdly I see a lot of parallels
between george RR martin and ramsey
ramsay has this very it's a very
manipulative streak and sometimes he can
use it to sort of gain people's
affection so if you think about like
when he was talking to Theon he builds
him up because he needs him to do
something he builds him up and then
ultimately just says you know like at
the last minute pulls the rug out from
under his feet is like but remember who
you are I feel like George does that a
lot with some of the story likes he'll
he makes you think that you're safe and
you're fine and then he just sort of
completely kills all the characters you
love or just has a little mini and mini
genocide a wedding or yeah you know it's
it's very manipulative but I can't deny
that I absolutely love it so speaking of
Ramsey actually this is another theory
that I have at the end of every single
season it tends to end well for at least
one person so season one you've got
Joffrey he was just killed Ned to prove
his power and kind of you know torture
Sansa you've got De Niro since season
one as well who gets some dragons
dragons are good season two you've got
robbed who's starting to win this war
season three you've got Stannis who
starts to sacrifice children that's not
good halston but what turns out is that
every time the thing that they've done
to make that season end well for them
turns out to be their downfall so
Joffrey killing Ned you know that starts
a war that's bad De Niro scarce dragons
they turn out to be kind of difficult
who would know and so at this end of
season five I had a look it's ramsey in
the sand snakes who are doing the best
hmm like all they're doing is going
around killing people but that makes
them powerful but that could come back
to bite them in the ass and at the end
of season five we have Loras being not
very secretive about his sexuality and
being like what everybody knows and we
think that that might actually become
one of the pot lines in this season so
so what you're saying is george RR
martin is a sadist and we're masochistic
for enjoying Emma Thrones we're reek
we're worried cos we used to be Theon we
used to be in a position of power not
anymore we can be Theon again he chops
off our bits metaphoric
oh goodness take your poor face in
watching this episode though I kind of
Drew some really strange parallels and
you have to promise to hear me out
because it's a really weird one The
Princess Bride so obviously I don't know
if you've seen the movie now I'm gonna
spoil a little bit of it so in in the
movie that's care to name wesley who
gets killed and he's taken to this
miracle miracle max played by Billy
Crystal a miracle max is basically get
able to bring Wesley back from the dead
because he's only mostly dead like he's
not fully dead he hasn't been dead that
long and I kind of think that in this
scenario Wesley is Jon Snow and miracle
max is Melisandre but wait there's more
god I hope so no right so Melisandre she
like she keeps putting all her money all
her bets on people that don't pan out so
look at Stannis she put all her money on
Stannis and then Stannis was just a
complete failure she put all my money on
John and then John ends up getting
betrayed by his own brothers so she's
obviously to have faith in the Lord of
Light is kind of winning and we see in
this episode you sort of seed the real
Melisandre you see her with without her
necklace on and she's like this old
saggy lady but in the princess bride
miracle max actually doesn't want to
resurrect Wesley Wesley because he got
fired from his last job and he he has a
real lack of confidence real crisis of
confidence he doesn't want to do it but
then he does do it because Wesley's only
mostly dead so maybe Melisandre's
realized that John is only mostly dead
because he hasn't been dead for that
long and that she may be can bring him
back also know there's an ulcer this
always and also there in the standoff
with sir Alistair and Davos Davos
requests and some mutton I'd like some
mutton mutton for the journey and if you
see the princess bride you all know that
miracle max is okay in miracle Max's
world the two greatest things one is
love true love the second greatest thing
in his life is a nice MLT mutton lettuce
tomato sandwich where the mutton is lean
okay so basically what I'm saying is
this is a really convoluted way of
saying well he's gonna bring John back
also she looked a bit like Billy Crystal
when cheddar old lady prosthetics on so
that's me drop mike I think you should
stick to the r+ l equals J and again
both there is no cuz this is my theory I
mean what what you're saying here is
that there's some tropes in this and
also Princess Bride about resurrecting
people I think no no no I think they're
dropping hints and the people who've
read and seen the princess roads mm-hmm
no because I also want to point out that
i don't know if you've seen american
horror story coven but there a someone
who can resurrect people in that and she
can only do it when they haven't been
dead for very long guys this is a show
like a game of thrones the martin is key
ok the martin is the key so if if a tree
falls in a forest does it make a sound
mmm if a game of thrones character dies
our screen are they really dead mmm i'm
gonna talk about an old favorite
character mine cast rebecca sure mine
back to series 1 Syrio Forel build Bravo
sea water dancer now I know people are
already type in the comments saying wait
the writers confirmed to Maisie Williams
that Syria is dead mmm well what if he
wasn't always Syria oh no so I think
potentially he could be the wife I think
it's more plausible that he is somehow
connected and still alive in there with
the many-faced God okay is he's still
hanging around so explain yourself sir I
intend to so we do see him have a fight
in series one after the Lannisters come
to take Arya Stark and he dispatches for
Lannister guards or Lannister guards
sought a wooden sword at that and then
he faces off with a Marin lovely summer
and Meryn Trant who breaks his sword and
you hear you hear you know combat as
areas running away but a few seasons
later area confides in the hound and
says marin killed my friend and he says
the greatest swordsman who ever lived
killed by Meryn [ __ ] truck is that
number any boy [ __ ] with a sword could
beat three Meryn Trant Syria didn't have
a sword all round my just a stick where
the sovereign over lived in have a
thought thank everyone pretty sure the
first sword of Braavos is better than
you know any boy [ __ ] with a sword so I
really don't think he's dead but where
is he now where is now well I feel like
to Braavos ok so there are some
definitely some parallels between the
Bravo sea water dancer and the man
without faces so he if he's not one that
he's definitely a part of them mmm so
the connection span of all 68 series I
mean obviously there's the what do we
say to the god of death that's fairly
obvious one but then he has a line the
full line is the heart lies and the head
plays tricks with us but the IC true
look at your eyes now area is currently
blind hmm and whose sight taken away
from her in the books serio actually
blindfolds area as part of her training
so maybe permanent blindness is an
extension of a training maybe the
blindfold was him preparing her for this
training all you have chance that she
would you know venture further down this
path are you with your logic well yeah
I've gotta have you know some good
moments and in the first lesson Mysterio
area turns up late just after midday and
he says tomorrow you'll be here at
midday throws restore she misses it
picks up tomorrow you'll catch it and
then the wave after battering her with a
stick or a wooden sword they're not the
same she says I will see you tomorrow I
maybe I'm just seeing what I want to see
maybe I'm holding onto that thing of if
they die off-screen are they really dead
maybe you're a fan of the musical Annie
maybe I've done a reference for sure
Parodi that as well like I got it do you
guys do you guys think that this theory
of the survival of the charismatic water
dancer holds water oh god that was worse
than mine um honestly deep down I want
it to be true and I think you've made
some good points there some less good
points also but I'm gonna play devil's
advocate here right first of all how
would serio or whatever
his real name is know that she was going
to end up in Braavos and be blind that's
pretty that's a pretty wild guess that
he would have to make it could just be
as his training that he had to the
madman our faces that he knew blindness
was a way to kind of a junior other
skills maybe they talk with each other
and so like maybe he knew Jack in her
car maybe he is jacking hung gar we just
don't know my second point is Dave
tomorrow is quite a common word I know
that try to point out the tap the the
parallels yeah okay daily training with
one person David training with another
moving wooden sticks hmm both having
their site taken away I mean it doesn't
happen in the first series of the show
but it happened to the books mm-hmm it's
happening Kate just a brace it will see
so excited serio is both in the show and
he's still here Oh Oh God all right so
now we've seen a next time on game of
thrones and we've heard some dark hints
dropped by the members of the cast let's
make some predictions Dave I know you've
got a great one about Ramsey right so in
season five we know that ruse
legitimized Ramsey's who's no longer
Ramsay snow mmm he's a true Bolton so
now that is alone no longer a bastard it
would make sense that he'd wants to to
keep his new title he's now the true
heir to his father you could inherit all
of everything the flayed man owns so now
the Santa's escaped his hold on that has
weakened they needed Sansa for the north
and he needed to produce an heir with
Sansa so in this episode Roose makes
quite a subtle threat to Ramsey without
sense that you won't be able to produce
an heir and without an heir well
let's hope the mesas are right and Lady
Walder's carrying a boy I think the
Ramsey will be so scared of losing his
his new role in the Bolton family and
he's also quite insane especially with
the grief is probably going through
after feeding his you know X to the dogs
I'm sure I'm sure that knocked him for
six is somewhat I think he will be
driven to kill lady Walda the unborn
claimant to his new title and possibly
his father who let it be noted doesn't
appear in any season six trailers which
might mean his pies I'm very big you
might be mine dying episode 2 and not
appear in the next day and you see
Ramsay the head of the Army's you do
also you see Ramsay cleaning his his
little blade blade almost as if he just
used it and he does someone is related
to he does have ultimate daddy issues
and when you've got daddy issues what's
what's the only way that can end killing
and you surfing your father whoa
psychology thank you dr. Freud but I
like that through a lot I kind of hope
that happens as well oh yeah poor lady
Walda yeah I mean she hasn't done
anything wrong she just you know had a
kid with a maniac hmm I've got a
prediction to mine is about Sansa Stark
so I know a lot of people myself
included weren't really very happy with
what happened to her in season five so
you know season four she comes out of it
and she's like a badass she's working
with Littlefinger she's been on
manipulative and then its season five
she just you know gets married after
ramsey and it's just sort of her his
punching bag and then she escapes swear
as this season you know we've been
promised that she's going to be you know
just sort of reclaim a lot of things be
a badass and she's already been poised
as being the key to the north so i think
the way that her season is kind of going
to go is that we know that the moments
of Bear Island are only going to answer
to a stark so she's also going to Castle
black with Briana and pod because she
knows that's where John is she's heard
that's what John is so she needs to go
find some families find some find some
help but I think she doesn't know that
John's dead so when she gets there
she's actually just gonna find Davos who
she's gonna ally with so she's gonna get
on board immediately Davos like the
loyal members of the Nights Watch and
the wildlings and with wildlings comes
Giants so I think unintentionally Sansa
is gonna become just basically queen of
the north and do a way better job of it
than Rob ever did because Rob just sort
of was immature didn't think ended up
marrying someone and you know basically
costing half his family whereas I think
Santa has been through so much and she's
learned from so many people she is
basically we're gonna become the boss
ass [ __ ] of the north and take on the
Bolton's I think that's what's gonna
happen with her Kate what do you think I
think she's never gonna trust anyone
again and I think that's definitely a
good thing in Game of Thrones like if
you remember back to season one little
finger says to Ned you should never have
trusted me and that's the whole point
that's the whole point of Game of
Thrones is just don't trust anyone even
Cersei shouldn't be trusting Jamie
mm-hmm so I think she's in a good
position to be queen of the North dave
is a great theory I can't wait to see
her in davao side by side what dream
team you're gonna cause some damage some
some well jus damage the buttons oh yeah
so hopefully we'll see you back in our
old home Winterfell pretty soon the
badass [ __ ] that she is so I know that
Ramses also on his way to Castle black
but we've also seen in the trailers
there is like a massive confrontation
outside Winterfell so I'm not entirely
sure if their paths will cross then or
if rams he'll just send you know his
twenty good man up to do his dirty work
for him but I really excited for that
big confrontation outside Winterfell but
that's not the only prediction ki know
you've got an amazing one about dragons
yes we talked about a little boring
people of Game of Thrones let's talk
about the badass dragons of Game of
Thrones so last time we saw Tyrion and
Varys they were wandering around the
city looking at all the abandoned places
all the broken things that everyone had
left behind and they mentioned that
people were afraid fear is properly into
a standstill whoever you are wherever
you go someone in this city wants to
murder you
now afraid people get angry angry people
riot we don't want that they have to
clean power while they're still in the
eye of the storm while there's still
space for a ruler to take control again
how are they going to do that because
generis she had her symbol of power
which was her dragons one of them's gone
where no know where he is anymore we've
got two left down in the catacombs so
we've seen tarian going down into
somewhere dark we've also seen the
Dragons being all dragony breathing fire
all over the place could those be the
same moment could tyrion be going down
to see the Dragons somehow making
friends with the Dragons could he be
doing that with the help of a red
priestess my theory is yes so we saw in
this episode that the red priesthood are
still loyal to Denarius which is really
handy known about someone yes so we see
some graffiti that's you know aunt Ida
naris you know kill all the Masters mrs.
a master and then shortly after that we
see red priest giving a sermon to a
small group of people which is the
biggest group of people we actually see
in marine in that episode saying things
like you know generis was great and you
love Denarius wasn't she nice and cool
but you know at living a little bit
paraphrasing it's something like that
and you know Tyrion and Varys they see
this and maybe something triggers in
their brain they go if we get the faith
on our side who knows what we could do I
mean the right priesthood they have Fire
Magic they have reservation powers it's
a pretty good thing to have on your side
so read precess plus dragon plus other
dragon equals great rulership that's my
theory I like that yeah I think they
don't need all the help they can get now
that their entire fleet of ships is just
burned down as well that did happen that
is a bad pretty stuck in marine yeah
gonna say that is kind of like sort of
settles it really that Daenerys and all
that log yeah stuck there for the fish
foreseeable future and good times build
boats that's the worst thing that
happens in the episode we've been
waiting five seasons for her to get her
stuff together and get over to Westeros
and be great
and now they're just like well we're not
going to Westeros anytime soon and
you're just okay fine time now for death
of the week um you know what to be
honest halfway through the episode I did
sort of think oh god there hasn't been
any good deaths are gonna have to use
some like no name but then luckily the
sand snakes finally did something
interesting and killed off poor Prince
trystane of dawn I was mourning as well
he was in mourning for his lost lady
love panting her beautiful blue eyes on
to some beautiful rocks and then it was
just oh god the two sand snakes and
they're awful banter also they're in an
enclosed room I don't see how a spear or
be a whip was going to be useful in an
enclosed area but there we are well good
on you sand snakes for giving us the
goriest and spa and best death of the
episode easily you good
smart boy
you're a greedy [ __ ] you know that so
that was our rundown of season 6 episode
1 the red woman episode 2 home Dave you
excited definitely after all the things
they've set up in episode 1 there's a
lot of entry going on in the north you
need all those help the hell from the
wildlings and everything else going on
the south and across the Narrow Sea I'm
looking forward to seeing what they can
develop on all these like new plot
points that we've been given and
hopefully see some more rad fighting but
not only that we're getting Brown back
okay if you miss Brian it's been like
two years a guy who's named after the
worst serial is really not gonna be the
best character that's all i have to say
boo bran oh I don't know he's finally
meeting the green Sears he's getting his
wings no no brand love no I hope he dies
off a cliff let's still go Brad in five
episodes race prove this all wrong yeah
one like Brian suddenly the best thing
never happened in Game of Thrones ah but
let me know your thoughts stick them in
the comments below I come find us on
Twitter I met Lucy James games Kate I'm
at how not to draw and Dave I am at a
regular Dave thanks watching gamespot of
Thrones this week guys be sure to join
us again next Monday gamespot com or
youtube.com slash gamespot for more
Westerosi action we'll see you then